let's talk about this story we got from
the hill youtube temporarily suspends
and demonetizes dan bongino's channel
this is huge notably because dan bongino
plays a huge role in rumble i believe
he's one of their principal investors
and he's been moving off the platform
anyway not to mention his podcast the
audio version is one of the biggest in
the world the hill says
youtube took action against conservative
commentator dan bongino's channel friday
suspending it for violating the
platform's covet 19 misinformation
policy and demonetizing it for at least
30 days
the week-long posting suspension stems
from a video where bongino said that
masks are useless in stopping the spread
of the disease youtube's covet 19 policy
specifically prohibits content denying
the effectiveness of wearing masks which
the vast majority of the scientific
community agrees reduces the risk of
infection this is true even the front
line doctors have said to wear masks
this is one of the things that really
bothers me but dan bongino in my opinion
is entitled to his opinion youtube doing
this is driving a nail into their own
platform
and not only that
useless is it a fact statement or a
hyperbolic statement is he saying it's
not effective enough and just being
hyperbolic was his intention to say that
they do nothing or that they don't do
enough is the issue there's no room for
nuance when i see things like this it
says to me that youtube's actual intent
is just get rid of people like dan
bongino yeah people that are on their
way out anyway and they're like well
he's obviously sending his energy into
rumble right now and he's and he's
driving viewers from youtube too exactly
so they're like cut him off now but i do
want to point this out too for a lot of
people because we've had people on the
show question the effectiveness of masks
it is true on the box on the mask box
says it doesn't stop you know the covet
virus right but it does stop you from
spinning on people and and for some
reason there was this flipping where
early the pandemic conservatives wanted
to wear masks and then all of a sudden
didn't and now we're in this this era
where the right is saying you know
things like masks are useless let me
just say this i've looked at a bunch of
studies and a bunch of data the virus as
my understanding can be transmitted
aerosolized through vapor as well as
from spit if you're spinning if you're
wearing a mask you're blocking that spit
and i think it's fairly obvious that
would stop you from spinning on people
and help reduce the transmission of
covid the frontline coalition of doctors
that they do the mask protocol and talk
about alternative treatments actually
tell people to wear masks as well so i i
don't understand why there's like a
tribal thing to say not wear them that
being said i oppose the suspension i
oppose the censorship obviously but you
know what if it builds up rumble i'm not
necessarily even the biggest fan of
rumble mind you but if it if it if it
breaks the youtube monopoly then so be
it let them be their own demise
i think youtube is also dealing with a
very tough situation rogan getting 40
million to 50 million views according to
some estimates with his latest
interviews with dr malone dr mccullough
and i think those big huge instances
that everyone's talking about is
something that of course youtube is
missing out on and that's why we even
talked about a few days ago why joe
rogan's move to spotify was a kind of
genius move a smarter move because
youtube could deal without having rogan
on their platform but spotify can't
youtube's already censoring you know the
videos that were on there but but there
comes a certain point where people start
seeing youtube for what it is and i
think youtube is reaching this kind of
pivotal point where they're like holy
crap everyone's kind of jumping ship
here what do we do i think this is a a
kind of very important turning stone
moment where a lot of people are asking
the questions where do we go next
turning stone moment yes we need another
leukism
that's a good one yes i don't know what
a turning stone is but i do like the
sound of it we should make like a root a
stone with like you know ancient
carvings on it you know changing the
narrative the turning stone no i think
you know what we're seeing right now the
fear and panic over joe rogan and i i
believe what we're seeing here from
youtube is fear and panic over dan
bongino
so there have been a bunch of people we
were talking to the ceo of rumble who
was saying that people do live streams
on youtube and then tell everybody okay
the rest of the show will only be on
rumble so they simulcast at the same
time on both platforms and then halfway
through the show say bye bye youtube and
turn it off to drive everyone to the
other platform that's massive yes that's
that's very damaging dan bongino puts
his show on rumble suspending him will
do nothing in fact it will just hurt
youtube now my ultimate fear is
youtube plays a dirty game
they google alphabet they subsidize
youtube so it's very difficult for the
likes of say rumble to compete with a
partner program like youtube where
google gets all this money from external
sources and then pays people yep but as
super chats are becoming the principal
driver of revenue you look at salty
cracker who's on rumble and we were
talking to the ceo of rumble and he's
like this guy is getting insane amounts
of super chats he's doing better than he
would be on youtube because people
support him and they're involved and
you'll get a better community on these
other platforms i don't know if rumble's
the answer but you know what with the
more i see the censorship let these big
tech companies be their own demise it's
not yeah i wouldn't say that rumble is
the answer but it it's definitely a
soothing mechanism for the pain
you know for the moment it's not solving
the problem of tech censorship because
it's still a proprietary sensorable
network that is censoring actively it's
just more maybe more judicious in its
censorship currently
um i you know i'm all for it but we got
to free the software code the the
absurdity of the youtube position on
this as it pertains to covet
misinformation is that so much changes
every single day from even dr fauci
himself
how are we supposed to know what the
rules are or abide by rules when the
science keeps changing there's a meme of
faucius vader where he's like that
science has changed pray i don't change
it further you know the line you know
he's like the deal has changed or
whatever the arrangement so
when we're looking at their policy
uncovered misinformation and then you
get breaking news where it's like in new
york they have record-breaking cases
what are we supposed to say what how are
you even supposed to follow those rules
unless you are blind to history to even
recent history and you just repeat
whatever it is the mainstream media is
saying right you're going to get banned
whenever they feel like well
that's a great point because what you're
saying means that it's all about
controlling who's able to shape and
drive narratives
you can exist downstream from sanctioned
narratives and you're fine
but if if you're in the business of
shaping narratives then you're in
trouble because you can't get out ahead
of the mainstream authoritative sources
yes simple as that this is part of
what's leading to impact invest impact
investing have you followed this impact
investing sorry my headphones just cut
out and back in have you heard of this
at all impact investments this is like
21st century people with big money are
coming to basically buy off influence
it's all about purchasing influence yeah
and getting ahead of it well i mean
influence is incredibly important now
you know arguably more important than
money
and that's how it's treated influences
and you know the the media really is in
the business of creating people's
reality and that the the system needs
that to sustain itself the entire
ecology of how the ruling class exists
the regime exists it all rests on
shaping narratives for people and that
that's why it's more important than any
profit and why profit motive is not
never going to be the ultimate factor in
any major media organization controlling
the myth do you do you remember when
michael brzezinski said that
i don't remember she said it's our
meeker business he said it's our job to
control what people think or something
like that i understand there's this
shared community that's bigness
brzezinski's uh daughter by the way
who's also a very interconnected
globalist but the big aspect here is
that this was a temporary suspension
this is why i think this is an important
moment with youtube at first cutting don
bongino off and then coming back and
saying okay we'll give you your money
back i think they're in a desperate
situation i think they're losing a lot
of key critical viewers i think overall
people are realizing hey i don't want to
be dictated to i don't want an algorithm
curating what i should see i don't want
my perspective limited to a few tech
oligarchs and their flip flop wearing
yate latte drinking limousine liberal
viewpoints i don't want that i want the
internet that was first given to us that
was free that was open that was weird
that was wild i loved when i was able to
go on there and see raw humanity in
front of us and not a corporate disney
world viewpoint that is watered down to
save slogans and talking points and i
think youtube is is realizing that and i
think i mean
they're making a big change here and
that's why i think they brought back
monetization for bongino let's brought
back what do you mean
temporarily no no he's kicked out of the
partner program he has to reapply in one
month he's done he's out but let's play
a fun game this is called
micah miko brzezinski whatever our job
to control people think followed by her
public statement after the fact let me
play the audio for you exactly and that
is that's exactly what i hear what you
meet just said is what i hear from all
the trump supporters that i talked to
who were trump voters
and are still trump supporters they go
yeah you guys are going crazy he's doing
what are you so surprised about he's
doing exactly what he said he's going to
do well and i think that
the dangerous you know edges here are
that he's trying to undermine the media
trying to make up his own facts and it
could be that while unemployment and uh
the the economy worsens he could have
undermined the messaging so much that he
can actually
control
uh exactly what people think and that is
the that is our job yeah if you look at
the
and that is our job she said and then
she tweets today i said it's the media
job to keep president trump from making
up his own facts not that it's our job
to control what people think yo she said
trump could make up you know he could
tell people exactly what to think but
that's our job yeah right and then she
tweets she didn't say it right that's
that you got to be a special kind of
stupid to fall for the media at this
point i'm sorry man
i just i just can't deal with these
people i think that uh when you talk
about a shared mythology humans need one
otherwise they fight so we had
christianity for religion is developed
basically shared myth and now like news
media is kind of like a shared mythology
everyone can tune in and organize and
believe the same thing but
obviously when they're lying to you you
don't want that myth we gotta find a
more stable
real myth but what what do we do in this
fractured information economy what's the
real
mythology of today their ratings are
down by ninety percent
i'm you know i'm gonna do i'm gonna have
some champagne
i'm gonna sit back we're gonna have a
good night's friday night we got news
earlier in the week that the msnbc and
cnn's ratings are down by 90 guess what
our ratings are going up that's right
your your your viewership is going up so
you know what i don't care about these
people i love exposing them and showing
these these duplicitous
uh evil people are lying to you and
manipulating and i i long for a world
where people they assume personal
responsibility they work hard they
strive to be the best person they can be
and that's only only that only will be
possible when they're getting correct
information for which to build their
lives off of
yep
and there's even poll numbers showing
that americans trust the media on kovid
for an estimated uh ten percent of
americans ten percent of americans trust
the media when it comes to code just
that little yup amazing you gotta be
careful fauci's at 31 i think even if
the media is being honest like if i draw
a six on the table and you're like
that's a nine and i'm like that's a six
darren and then we get into an argument
we're both right but we're
obviously not saying the same we're
seeing different things but we're both
right
so even if a media is is being honest
with you you're still going to have
people seeing different things
and
we got to figure out a way to
communicate a shared like understanding
of reality even when we're seeing it
differently you know what i think i
think i'm going to buy a bunch of cnn
schwag and memorabilia because it's
going to be you know now that they're
about to they're collapsing and
crumbling yeah it's going to become you
know like once cnn is gone people get
like oh whoa i remember that i see him
in the air gonna be like the uh buffalo
nickel that's right that's right it'll
be like it'll be it'll be five years
from now and i'll be like yo check this
out i got a cnn mug
crystal pepsi yeah
good
good you know what man we have a
decentralizing media environment there's
good things and there's bad things about
it with the the bad is that some people
you know go off in rabbit holes that can
happen but for the most part you end up
with um you know on youtube and now with
competition forming on rumble the
ability to get multiple voices of
differing opinions which gives you a
healthier diet when you go on one of
these platforms and this is why i think
it's bad that youtube is censoring
people because here's the benefit
you can go on youtube and look up
something about immigration you can find
videos from me kind of moderate you can
find videos from crowder more
conservative videos from jimmy dore
anti-establishment left and maybe even
you know the young turks establishment
left you get all of those different
views you get a healthier diet through
youtube youtube censorship is turning
them into everything wrong with cnn and
msnbc that all their hosts tell the
exact same line say the exact same thing
and do not give you a healthy
perspective
i like the fact that there's more
websites more channels more
personalities that people have less
centralized power in this because now
you can have people who watch this show
watch crowder and jimmy dore and be like
hey tim you were wrong about this jimmy
dore said this and crowder said this and
i can be like oh how oh wow good good
point
more voices better
right
censorship bad uh diminishing return
more voices better diminishing return on
that for sure you have too many voices
then it becomes incoherent although as
long as you can select the way you view
the voices maybe more voices the better
i don't understand how youtube thinks
that they could have a future when
they're trying to shove down our throats
this nasty crap that is cnn that people
don't even want to watch in airports and
hotel rooms i think that was given up i
mean their viewership is going down
dramatically as tim just mentioned but
and and this is this is their strategy
whenever you look up something user
related we get cnn something that people
overwhelmingly don't like how can a
business keep well again again it gets
to the point it's not a business in the
usual sense and the fact that they are
continuing this trajectory of presumably
hurting their customer experience and so
forth indicates for one that that's
they're not their primary objective is
to be important because they don't
really have to they're subsidized by the
most powerful company in the world
essentially and secondly
it shows the more that they censor it
shows that they're actually betting on
all of these incipient alternatives to
be crushed in some fashion or another
and i think that's another thing that we
should really think about is that yes
you know rumble's growing and these
alternatives are growing
but there might be just an ultimate
bottleneck to a genuine alternative to
what youtube was supposed to be and when
something gets to be too influential and
too subversive
the regime will find ways to destroy it
that's true but they are losing it looks
like and you know we have we have this
funny article i don't think we'll get
into it in greater detail but joe rogan
mocks together
saying i don't know how to get off he
complained the site artificially bloats
follower counts by including a person's
twitter following and he's right about
that i don't i like getter there's a lot
of users on it that's important but i do
think gab is substantially better in
that they run their own infrastructure
and they're actually challenging the
establishment becoming a real thorn well
it's just a different enterprise you
know their gab is really doing a full
spectrum like they're taking very
seriously the idea of just build your
own ex and they're doing it with the
platform with the server with this
browser with the payment process they're
they're going full spectrum and they're
they're just playing a very different
game a much more difficult game i give
them tremendous credit for you know
andrew torba for his ambition his
persistence his boldness
um and you know i wish him all the best
in it but i really think if if you want
to be at on the main stage as a
communications platform you're
ultimately going to come up to that
bottleneck of the national security
state and of the regime
and they have many ways to uh to deal
with emerging threats like this they can
go after centralized services of any
kind so if you control the logins if you
control the passwords if you store any
data the cia can come take it at any
moment so you want to decentralize
services in that manner and they can
also take your code your source code and
force force you to shut up and do what
they want and if you're the only one
that has the code they basically lock it
in and they they make it do what they
want so you free the code out so that if
you get stuck at least the code's still
out there for people to wrap up more or
less
cyber communism i don't know
we we argue about the free the code
thing i don't think it's a solution it's
for me it's a vulnerability for this for
the deep state to take a hold of your
company if that's the only place where
that code can is exists
i just don't if someone builds code the
code belongs like to them and then the
cia it belongs to the cia
no if google builds it the cio yeah
controls it basically unfortunately take
a drink everyone ian said free the code
and it is another one we need a bingo
card
but i imagine along with what darren
what you're saying is that they will the
government does come when the
organization gets big enough and will
start to control it from the right even
look at parlor as you know parlor
i i think it's fair to say is a joke
compared to
gab and it's a joke compared to
getter and even in that case when it
looked like oh it might be some type of
threat
january 6 completely destroyed it
yeah you know on top of i think probably
incompetence and and so forth but all it
served was oh there's a bunch of
chaturang parlor pertaining to this
insurrection event
now all of a sudden it is a vehicle for
threatening the national security state
and it's treated like a threat and that
gets back full circle back to the
lindell situation is that if you are a
genuine threat to the regime or in any
in any remote sense you become iran
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time